[Música]
Perú retiró de manera definitiva a su
embajador en Colombia según el gobierno
peruano la medida se da a raíz de los
comentarios del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro en torno al destituido
presidente Pedro castillo y que Lima
considera como injerencistas
México Investiga como presunto homicidio
la muerte de 39 personas en el interior
de un centro migratorio en Ciudad Juárez
el gobierno Indicó que identificó a ocho
personas que podrían tener
responsabilidad en el incendio imágenes
reveladas muestran como los guardias de
seguridad no abrieron las rejas a los
migrantes mientras se avivaban las
llamas
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden recibió en la casa blanca su
homólogo argentino Alberto Fernández y
aseguró que es una oportunidad clave
para afianzar los lazos con la nación
suramericana a su vez Fernández aseguró
que biden le dijo que contará con él
para respaldar las negociaciones de
Buenos Aires con el fondo monetario
internacional
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú la atención diplomática entre el
gobierno de este país y el de Colombia
escaló la noche del miércoles con La
retirada definitiva del embajador
peruano en Bogotá nuestro corresponsal
en Lima Francisco Zacarías con los
detalles el gobierno peruano considera
que son constantes ofensivas y
reiteradas las expresiones injerencistas
del presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
hacia este país el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores a través de un
comunicado ha señalado que estas
expresiones el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro lo que han hecho es dañar
las históricas relaciones de amistad y
cooperación entre Perú y Colombia que
han venido llevando más de 200 años la
cancillería de este país ha señalado que
el presidente de Gustavo Petro lo que ha
hecho es ofender a esta nación y a los
ciudadanos porque el mandatario Colombia
desconoce que lo que ocurrió el 7 de
diciembre de 2022 en esta nación fue un
golpe de estado perpetrado por el
expresidente Pedro Castillo Gustavo
Petro ha señalado a lo largo de estos
días en que Perú sacó del poder a Pedro
castillo y quien es Inocente de todo
cargo y viene pagando una prisión
injustamente así como están las cosas
ahora las relaciones diplomáticas entre
Perú y Colombia quedan a nivel de
encargados de negocios una situación
similar se produjo el 24 de febrero
cuando la presidenta peruana Dina
boluarte retiró al embajador peruano en
México Porque también se sentendió
ofendida con las versiones que ha venido
difundiendo el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador sobre Perú y
su gobierno pasamos a México la fiscalía
identificó a ocho presuntos responsables
del incendio a una estación migratoria
en Ciudad Juárez que dejó 39 personas
muertas entre ellos federales un agente
Estatal de migración así como cinco
agentes de una empresa de seguridad
privada el órgano judicial también
Indicó que la situación está siendo
investigada como presunto homicidio la
fiscalía dijo que el personal no actuó
para evacuar a los migrantes en medio
del fuego el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pidió que no haya
impunidad mientras que Estados Unidos
dijo que estaba siguiendo de cerca la
situación y ofreció ayuda a las
autoridades mexicanas repr
obamos la mala actuación de servidores
públicos que no se apegaron a los
protocolos de protección a la vida se
inició la carpeta para el delito de
homicidio y por el delito de daño en
propiedad ajena pero de acuerdo a las
investigaciones se realizarán otros
delitos las personas no están detenidas
hasta que no exista esta orden de
aprehensión y se se complementa en estas
órdenes en el caso de ser concedidas sin
embargo están identificados y han estado
en la delegación de la fiscalía general
de la república declarando un video
publicado por la agencia routers muestra
cómo los guardias del centro de
detención de migrantes en Ciudad Juárez
no abrieron las rejas cuando el incendio
comenzó además en el vídeo se ve como
las personas atrapadas patean las vallas
para escapar mientras dos guardias de
seguridad salen del recinto en esos
momentos grupos de activistas denuncian
la responsabilidad de los funcionarios
en las muertes por presunta inacción
Andrés granadillo tiene los detalles
en las imágenes de las cámaras de
seguridad de la estación del Instituto
Nacional de Migración en Ciudad Juárez
se ve el momento en el que inicia el
incendio en el que murieron 38 migrantes
y a unos guardias de seguridad que pasan
frente a la cámara y parecen salir del
recinto al menos hasta ese momento no
abren las puertas de las celdas donde
estaban los detenidos el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador quien había
responsabilizado del incidente a los
migrantes en el centro por según él
oponerse a ser deportados y un giro a
sus declaraciones y dijo que
investigaría los hechos debido a las
nuevas versiones que han salido a la luz
se están haciendo
todas las investigaciones para
conocer lo que realmente
sucedió una información preliminar pero
queremos tener
todos los elementos para informar
si es posible hoy mismo
informar sobre lo que sucedió
en
la versión de
el gobierno que represento
al frente del centro donde ocurrió la
conflagración un grupo de migrantes
protestaba por la falta de información y
por el trato que han recibido
a toda esa persona que tuvieron ahí que
fallecieron les pudieron abrir la reja
porque de la reja a donde se para los
agentes de migración son
ni metros hay un tremendo de hermetismo
hay mucho silencio nadie dice nada el
Gobierno Federal ni migración ni el
gobierno del Estado ni el gobierno
municipal en medio de la oleada
migratoria que enfrenta a México el
embajador de Estados Unidos en este país
que en Salazar dijo que la tragedia era
un recordatorio para los gobiernos de la
región de la importancia de arreglar un
sistema migratorio que no funciona y los
riesgos de la migración irregular
pasamos a Washington donde el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden recibió a su
homólogo argentino Alberto Fernández El
Líder latinoamericano pidió a biden que
siga apoyando su país en las
negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional al tiempo que el
mandatario estadounidense resaltó el
encuentro como una oportunidad para
fortalecer los lazos entre las dos
naciones la ampliación de esta noticia
desde la capital estadounidense con
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
fue un encuentro que se iba a dar el año
pasado pero precisamente por temas de
covid no se dio este es esta es la
primera vez que una el presidente
argentino kicherista se reúne en la casa
blanca con un mandatario estadounidense
después de que lo hiciera con el
presidente el expresidente Bush se habló
de varios temas pero el tema económico
fue central sobre todo de Cara a esta
línea de crédito que quiere Argentina
para solventar la situación económica
que vive el país el presidente Alberto
Fernández le dijo que Argentina en este
momento cuando ocurre la guerra en
Ucrania y
las consecuencias de esta guerra están
derivando en menos alimentos Argentina
puede ser una opción para precisamente
ofrecerle al mundo más alimentos y más
energía y esos temas también se tocaron
en esta reunión bilateral después se
ofreció una rueda de prensa en la
Embajada Argentina donde varios líderes
y varios ministros que acompañaron
Alberto Fernández calificaron esta
reunión de positiva la presidenta de
Taiwán say in wén llegó a la ciudad de
Nueva York que este miércoles en un
viaje que amenaza con generar nuevas
tensiones entre China y Estados Unidos
beijin advirtió que habría consecuencias
si la mandataria llega a reunirse con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano que vio
mccarthy pero el gobierno estadounidense
le pidió a China que no exagere al
respecto ya que el paso de Zayn Wayne
por Nueva York y también por los Ángeles
solo es una escala de su viaje a
Centroamérica y no corresponde a una
visita oficial
la presidenta de Honduras Xiomara Castro
anunció que viajará pronto a China la
decisión de la mandataria se conoce Poco
después de que Tegucigalpa rompiera
lazos con Taiwán esta semana el gobierno
hondureño dio un plazo de 30 días para
que Taiwán cerrara su embajada en el
país centroamericano tras romper lazos
con este territorio
en Chile el Ministerio de salud confirmó
el primer caso de gripe aviar en un
humano que fue reportado en un hombre de
53 años en la zona norte las autoridades
informaron que el paciente presenta un
cuadro de influenza grave pero que se
encuentra estable al tiempo de
destacaron que ya se investiga la fuente
de contacto y si existen antecedentes de
otros afectados entre el círculo cercano
del hombre el Ministerio de salud llamó
a la ciudadanía a no manipular aves o
mamíferos enfermos o muertos e instó a
los trabajadores avícolas a seguir los
protocolos de seguridad correspondientes
y a vacunarse contra la influenza
estacional
terminamos con una noticia en Ecuador
porque la corte constitucional del país
dio luz verde a un juicio político
contra el actual presidente Guillermo
lasso la resolución fue aprobada por
seis votos a favor y tres en contra
sigan los avances de esta noticia en
nuestros próximos informativos hasta
aquí esta misión de noticias en France
24 Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]